There's the,
you talked about the
availability heuristic and
some of the role that the press
might be playing,
the fact that negative events stand out.
We can also see negative
events all over the world now,
so we can't fake of all over the world.
Whenever you hear about a negative event,
it's as if it's happening
next door and this is,
he is a threat.
So are the breadth of our
news is exaggerated and the
coverage is exaggerated,
but there still seems to me to be this,
this mystery at the bottom of all this,
which is in the face of
such radically good news.
Why is there such an insistence
that the system is corrupt?
We're going to hell in
a handbasket then that,
you know,
human beings are a cancer on the planet
and everything is heading towards the
apocalypse.
It's,
it's so,
it's so deep and,
and it doesn't seem to be
moved by the fact much.
I kind of think sometimes that
it's a hangover from the cold war,
you know,
that was so deeply
pessimistic for so long.
Uh,
I think it goes back before the Cold War.
It certainly as a,
as a psychological syndrome,
it goes back at least to the Old Testament
prophets who combined kind of social
criticism with,
uh,
for telling a apocalyptic
disaster that slat that syndrome.
That combination of,
uh,
moral schooling with predictions of
doom is something that our species quite
naturally falls into.
Part of it is frankly,
certain amount of,
uh,
perfect interprofessional competition
that society has various elites.
Uh,
there's the politicians,
the business people,
the military,
religious elites,
the academics,
the journalists,
and they're always kind
of competing for status.
And since intellectuals don't deserve a
whole lot of credit for getting society
to run for,
for putting food in the stores
and that keeping the peace and,
and,
uh,
protecting the streets,
it's very easy to,
uh,
to look down on other societal elites on,
on government,
on business and to say,
well,
you guys are all failing and we're the
ones who are morally refined enough to
point it out.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't put down just a
sheer human competitiveness.
I'm not the first to say this.
One of my favorite explanations
of the veneration of,
uh,
of the past of Golden Ages comes from
Thomas Hobbs who said competition of
praise inclined to a reverence of
antiquity or men contend with the living,
not with the dad.
Yeah.
Well it also seems that the,
um,
there's a certain amount of resentment
that is driving that as well.
And that would go along with the status
competition because there's anger,
I suppose if you're a member of any
meat group to see that your paradigm,
let's say isn't leading
the charge forward.
MMM,
that's right.
And you talked about the astonishing in
global poverty and a part of that story
is it did not come about
through massive redistribution,
which for,
for many people on the left was the
only route to lifting up the poor,
namely to,
to redistribute resources.
Now that have been of course,
adjust adjustments either to shocks the
fact that China and India and Bangladesh
and Indonesia have risen out of poverty,
uh,
came in part of the expense of
manufacturing jobs in the United.
Yeah.
That's not exactly what people
meant by redistribution.
And it literally is a
redistribution of resources.
Uh,
although it is a shaking up
of the economies of many,
many nations.
But this massive increase in the wealth
of that Asian countries did not come
because it was horses were,
uh,
were shipped from the wealthy
west to the impoverished east.
Right.
So that's also a threat
to the doctrine itself.
Direct threat,
the fact that wealth is being produced
and it's being distributed to people at
the low end means that implies that that
redistributive philosophy is likely in
error.
And you can understand why that might
be regarded as a catastrophic threat,
particularly to people
on the radical left.
Well,
certainly,
certainly for,
for a radical notions of redistribution,
but at the same time,
the more limited kinds of
redistribution that have,
uh,
that are ubiquitous in wealthy countries,
I have a graph showing that the amount,
the proportion of GDP allocated to
social spending a skyrocketed in the 20th
century from about 1% to about
22% in every developed country.
No exceptions.
Uh,
and,
uh,
thanks to,
to spending on the cooler
on children on the sick,
uh,
on the online rates of absolute
poverty have fallen in,
in a wealthy countries.
So not only,
uh,
have,
has been developed developing worlds
become wealthier and not directly at the
expensive of the developed world,
but it within the developed world,
thanks to some amount of social spending,
I guess you could call it redistribution.
The even as inequality has risen,
poverty has not.
Right,
right.
I wonder,
I was just reading a book by Walter
Shadelle called the great leveler.
Yeah,
excellent.
It is an excellent book.
And one of the things he did
was an empirical analysis
of left versus right wing
governments,
I think across the 20th century,
but it might've gone farther back to
now to see if there is any difference in
the Gini Coefficient across
the classes of government.
And what he found was that there
was no difference whatsoever.
He makes a fairly strong case that the
only redistributive techniques that work
are,
um,
pestilence and war essentially.
And that's because they
knock everyone down to zero.
But you're making a different case,
like an incremental case in some sense,
which is that governments
perhaps regardless of their
ideological proclivities
in the 20th centuries as
they've become more wealthy,
they have incrementally
devoted a larger part of their,
uh,
of their resources to
incremental improvements in,
you might think about it as an
investment in the future rather than
redistribution or investment in social
capital education and healthcare and
those sorts of things that,
well,
it's pounded with some,
it's probably some combination.
It's a combination of investment in
public goods because of course the whole
society is better off if the,
if everyone's educated.
I also want assurance people support,
uh,
a a safety net.
That's the most popular euphemism for
social spending because you never know
whether it's going to be you or your or
your mother or your brother who is going
to be,
who's going to be a need in
the lottery of misfortune.
I had been,
part of it's part of it is,
is a,
is charity.
He,
the modern conscience won't allow the
little match girl to freeze to death.
The jokes to Barry,
Grandpa by the side of route 66.
And so I think social spending
has been pushed along by,
by all three.
Uh,
it hasn't necessary in some countries
it probably has reduced the Gini
Coefficient in western European countries,
which have a more,
uh,
aggressive system of taxation then
in the United States or Canada.
But more important than the
Jenny distribution is that
it's reduced the number
of people living in poverty,
which is the morally relevant
measuring in any case.
Yeah.
So those two things are complicated
because obviously you want to raise people
out of abject poverty.
I mean that's,
that's a,
that's a zero argument proposition and
that seems to be happening very rapidly.
The theme,
the question after that I suppose is to
what degree does the remaining degree of
inequality that's generated by productive
capital assistance also constitute a
social threat?
Is there is evidence it was reviewed
best buy in the spirit level,
that as inequality increases
rates of male homicide,
for example,
increase in all sorts of
other negative measures.
So there's some weird interaction between
raising absolute levels of wealth and
ensuring that inequality doesn't,
I don't know,
exceed some hypothetical optimum that
that needs to be considered in social
policy.
There I cite some skeptical
re analyses of the,
uh,
the data in the spirit level and,
probably absolute prosperity matters
more than inequality in determining a
social health include such as happiness,
crime,
um,
other kinds of social
pathologies like drug addictions.
Uh,
it's,
it's not easy to,
to tease them apart.
No,
definitely not.
These,
you know,
countries like Sweden
are a very egalitarian,
but they're also very rich,
are a more lopsided,
but they're also very poor.
And so it takes a little bit of
statistical wizardry to type them apart.
And my reading of the literature is that
it's actually prosperity that is more
important than that in any quality.
But also,
and this is a,
a,
that I in the psychological literature
was emphasized by Christina Storman's and
Paul Bloom,
that what people sometimes think of as an,
uh,
as an aversion to inequality,
to people having different amounts
is actually an aversion to unfairness
injustice.
Yeah.
That,
but people that really infuriates people
is that they think that the people at
the top half ill gotten gains equal.
If they sense that the
system is basically fair,
that either greater effort,
talent,
or even luck,
uh,
result in an unequal distribution,
by an impartial library,
for example.
They're okay with that.
It's cheating that really gets under,
yeah,
people are really good at remembering
cheating and recognizing it as well.
And stitching.